La nature est ma muse et ma passion.
En tant que photographe pour National Geographic, je l'ai représentée pour que beaucoup la voient.
Mais il y a 5 ans, j'ai commencé un voyage personnel.
Je voulais représenter l'histoire de la vie.
C'est ce que j'ai tenté de plus difficile dans ma vie,
et j'ai eu envie d'abandonner de nombreuses fois.
Mais j'ai également eu des révélations.
Dont une que j'aimerais partager avec vous aujourd'hui.
Je suis allé dans un lagon isolé en Australie, dans l'espoir de voir la Terre
telle qu'elle était il y a 3 milliards d'années,
avant que le ciel ne devienne bleu.
Le fond est couvert de stromatolithes --
les premiers organismes à faire la photosynthèse --
et c'est le seul endroit où on peut encore en trouver.
Descendre là-bas était comme entrer dans une machine à remonter le temps,
et j'en suis sorti avec une perception différente de moi-même dans le temps.
L'oxygène produit par ces stromatolithes
est ce que nous respirons tous ajourd'hui.
Les stromatolithes sont les héros de mon histoire.
J'espere que cette histoire résonnera dans notre époque.
C'est une histoire qui parle de vous et moi, de la nature et de la science.
Cela étant dit, je vous invite à
un court voyage de la vie à travers le temps.
Notre voyage commence dans l'espace, où la matière se condense en sphères au fil du temps.
Elles se solidifient en surface, sculptées par le feu.
Le feu a cessé, la Terre a émergé -- Mais il s'agit d'une planète étrangère.
La Lune était plus proche, les choses étaient différentes.
La chaleur du coeur faisait érupter des geysers -- ainsi sont nés les océans
L'eau a gelé aux pôles, et a façonné les bords de la Terre.
L'eau est source de vie, mais sous forme de glace, c'est une force endormie.
Et quand elle disparait, la Terre devient Mars.
Mais cette planète est différente -- elle remue de l'intérieur.
Et quand cette énergie touche l'eau, quelque chose de nouveau apparait: la vie.
Elle apparait dans des crevasses de la Terre.
La boue et les minéraux deviennent un substrat, il y a des bactéries.
Elles apprennent à se multiplier, à grossir par endroit.
Des structures vivantes qui grandissent sous un ciel étranger.
Les stromatolithes ont été les premiers à produire de l'oxygène.
Et ils ont changé l'atmosphère.
Un souffle fossilisé aujourd'hui devenu du fer.
Les météorites ont apporté la chimie, et peut être aussi des membranes.
La Vie a besoin d'être contenue dans une membrane
afin de pouvoir se répliquer et muter.
Ce sont des diatomées, du phytoplancton unicellulaire
avec des squelettes de silicium.
Les circuits imprimés du futur.
Les mers peu profondes ont très tôt bercé la vie, et c'est là qu'elle s'est transformée
en formes plus complexes.
Elle a grandi au fur et a mesure que la lumière et l'oxygène augmentaient.
La vie s'est endurcie et est devenue défensive.
Elle a appris à bouger et a commencé à voir. Les premiers yeux sont apparus sur les trilobites.
La vue s'est améliorée chez les limules,
qui furent parmi les premiers à quitter l'océan.
Ils continuent à faire ce qu'ils font depuis toujours, leur ennemis depuis lontemps disparus.
Les scorpions ont suivi les proies hors de l'eau. Les limaces sont devenues escargots.
Les poissons ont essayé la vie d'amphibien. Les grenouilles se sont adaptées aux déserts.
Le lichen est apparu en symbiose. Un champignon marié à une algue.
Accroché aux pierres, et s'en nourrissant. Transformant la terre désolée.
Les véritables plantes terrestres sont apparues, d'abord sans feuilles.
Une fois qu'elle on su rester droites, elles ont grandi et pris des formes diverses.
Les premières fougères ont suivi,
et ont porté des spores qui annonçaient les graines.
La vie a fleuri dans les marais.
Sur le sol, la vie a passé une étape. Les mâchoires d'abord se sont formées. Puis les dents.
Les tortues luth et les sphénodons sont des échos de cette ère.
Il a fallu du temps pour quitter l'eau,
et elle attire encore en permanence.
La vie s'est endurcie pour s'aventurer dans les terres.
Et les dragons qui sont apparus sont encore parmi nous aujourd'hui.
Jurassic Parc existe encore dans des coins de Madagascar,
et au centre du Brésil.
Les cycadophytes sont des plantes qui restent dures comme la pierre.
Les forêts ont surgi et ont protégé les créatures pourvues d'ailes.
L'une d'elle a laissé une empreinte, comme elle n'était morte qu'hier.
Et d'autres volent aujourd'hui, comme des échos du passé.
Avec les oiseaux, la vie a gagné en mobilité.
Les flamands ont conquis les continents, les migrations ont commencé.
Les oiseaux ont vu l'émergence des plantes à fleurs.
Les nénuphars ont été parmi les premiers
Les plantes se sont diversifiées et ont grandi, sont devenues des arbres.
En Australie, un nénuphar est devenu un xanthorrhoea
et à Hawaii, une pâquerette est devenue une argyroxiphium.
En Afrique, le Gondwana a façonné les Proteas.
Mais quand cet ancien continent s'est séparé, la vie est devenue plus luxuriante.
Des forêts tropicales sont apparues, et avec elles de nouveaux niveaux d'interdépendance.
Les champignons se sont multipliés. Les orchidées ont surgi, avec des organes génitaux faits pour attirer les insectes.
Une astuce utilisée par la plus grande fleur sur Terre.
L'évolution coopérative a lié les insectes, les plantes et les oiseaux ensembles pour toujours.
Quand les oiseaux ne peuvent voler, ils deviennent vulnérables.
Les Kiwis le sont, ainsi que ces faucons coincés prés de l'Antarctique.
Une extinction peut prendre du temps, mais arrive parfois à grande vitesse.
Un astéroïde frappe, et le monde part en fumée.
Mais il est resté des témoins, survivant dans l'obscurité.
Une fois les cieux dégagés, un nouveau monde était né.
Un monde pour les mamifères. A partir de musaraignes miniscules,
les tanrecs se sont habitués à l'obscurité.
De nouvelles formes. Des chauve-souris, des civettes.
De nouveaux prédateurs, les hyènes se déplaçant de plus en plus vite.
Les grandes plaines ont créé des opportunités.
La sécurité du troupeau a demandé des sens aiguisés
Une autre solution a été de grandir, mais la taille a toujours un prix.
Certains mammifères sont retournés dans l'eau.
Les morses ont développé des couches de graisse. Les lions de mer sont devenus lisses.
Et les cétacés sont allés dans un monde sans frontières.
On peut être mammifère de plusieurs façons. Un kangourou saute en Australie.
Un cheval court en Asie, et un loup développe des échasses au Brésil.
Les primates sortent des jungles, d'abord en tarsiers.
et deviennent des lémuriens peu de temps après.
L'apprentissage s'est renforcé. Des groupes de singes se sont aventurés à découvert.
Les forêts se sont asséchées une fois de plus. Se tenir debout est devenu un mode de vie.
Alors qui sommes-nous ? Frères de chimpanzés mâles.
Soeurs de femelles bonobo. Nous sommes tous ceux-là, et davantage.
Nous sommes formés par la même force de vie.
Le sang qui coule dans nos mains
se rappelle aux sillons de l'eau sur Terre.
Et nos cerveaux -- nos illustres cerveaux --
rappellent l'écoulement des eaux d'un marécage.
La vie est une force en soi. C'est un nouvel élément.
Elle a modifié la Terre, elle la recouvre comme une peau.
et là où elle n'est pas, comme au Groenland en hiver,
Mars n'est pas très loin.
Mais cette possibilité s'efface dès que la glace fond de nouveau.
Quand l'eau est liquide, elle devient une matrice.
Pour des cellules vertes de chlorophylle -- et cette merveille moléculaire
est ce qui fait la différence -- elle apporte son énergie à tout.
Le monde animal entier vit aujourd'hui avec une réserve
d'oxygène d'origine bactérienne, qui est renouvelée en permanence
par les plantes et les algues, leurs déchets nous permettent de respirer,
et vice versa.
Cette Terre est vivante, et elle a créé sa propre membrane.
On l'appelle l'atmosphère. C'est l'icone de notre voyage.
Vous pouvez tous imaginer aujourd'hui et créér notre futur.
(Applaudissements)
Merci, merci.